les députés vont voter dans quelques
minutes ce sera oui aux nationalisations
on y re étape du tour de france de
pierre mauroy aujourd'hui la bretagne le
premier ministre plaide pour un dialogue
entre chefs d'entreprise et syndicale
deux français raid moscou dans sept mois
l'un d'entre eux partira dans l'espace
sur soyouz
mais messieurs bonsoir nationalisation
fin de l'acte 1 dans quelques minutes
les députés vont donc clore le débat sur
le projet de loi gouvernemental de très
loin le débat le plus passionné de ce
début de législature
l'impact du congrès de valence n'aura
pas arrangé les choses
nous verrons tout à l'heure et l'appel
de françois mitterrand appelle à
l'apaisement n'a pas vraiment été
écoutés cela dit donc au terme d'une
guérilla d'amendements et de contre
proposition le débat va tout à l'heure
se clore par un vote nous vivons en ce
moment ce direct dès que le
dépouillement sachet avec le président
de séance
on donne le résultat nous le diffusons
sur cette antenne alors je parlais tout
à l'heure de l'acteur à l faut dire en
effet que la pièce n'est pas tout à fait
jouer reste encore à connaître l'avis du
sénat et du conseil constitutionnel et
dans les deux cas noël copal dénouement
n'est pas décrit mais parlons d'abord du
sénat il ne sera vraisemblement saisie
de ce texte qu au début du mois de
septembre de vieux mois de décembre
pardon vers le 6 et dont on sait très
bien qu'il ya une majorité qui est aussi
le gouvernement est hostile à son projet
de nationalisation mais le gouvernement
ayant décidé la procédure d'urgence cela
veut dire qu'il n'y aura qu'un examen
par les deux assemblées
la réunion d'une commission mixte
paritaire et en tout état de cause c'est
l'assemblée nationale qui a le dernier
mot alors cela dit on peut écarter tout
recours à des procédures exceptionnelles
c'est vraisemblable en tout cas ça ne
paraît pas être l'intention du
gouvernement en revanche si le débat des
nationalisations se prolongeait et
empêcher le débat sur le budget
d'aboutir avant la fin de la session
parlementaire le gouvernement serait
obligé la d'appliquer les mesures
exceptionnelles prévues par la
constitution c'est-à-dire de décréter
budget par ordonnance ça dit il ya une
autre instance et le conseil
constitionnel ce qui va être saisie
c'est très vraisemblable c'est même
certain il suffit donc que 60 députés ou
60 sénateurs saisisse le conseil
constitutionnel
et je crois que là il faut peut-être
faire de remarques et la première c'est
que le conseil constitutionnel ne
prononce pas un jugement politique le
rôle du conseil constitutionnel et de
dire si un texte de loi est conforme ou
non à la constitution et la deuxième
remarque c'est que ce jugement du
conseil constitutionnel ne portent pas
nécessairement sur la totalité d'un
texte il peut très bien décider que tel
ou tel article ou telle ou telle
paragraphe n'est pas conforme à la
constitution
non cela dit est ce que le gouvernement
peut passer outre cette année la réponse
est claire elle est dans l'article 62 de
la constitution c'est non une
disposition déclarée inconstitutionnelle
ne peut être promulguée ni mise en
application les décisions du conseil
constitutionnel s'imposent aux pouvoirs
publics
mais si l'on s'est posé la question
c'était la suite d'une déclaration de
lionel jospin le premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste qu'il y a quelques
jours à france inter disait jamais les
grands courants de réformes ne se sont
laisser arrêter par une cour suprême
quelles qu'elles soient alors je crois
que cette phrase n'a qu'une
signification politique celle d'une
détermination politique celle d'une
conviction c'est que le conseil
constitutionnel ne peut pas
politiquement aller contre la volonté
pour lionel jospin de la nation mais
cette phrase ne veux pas avoir un
caractère juridique il n'est pas
possible un gouvernement ni au président
de la république de se soustraire à des
décisions de cette nature du conseil
constitution d'un conseil un peu
spéciale depuis le 10 mai puisqu'il ya
un dixième membres oui alors justement
là il ya une question ne connaît pas
encore les intentions de valéry giscard
d'estaing qui est membre de droit en
tant qu'ancien président de la
république
à vrai dire on ne sait même pas si un
ancien président de la république est
obligé de prêter serment de ne rien
révéler des délibérations de ne faire
aucune déclaration publique sur les
sujets qui sont décidés par le conseil
constitutionnel
mais ce que l'on sait en revanche c'est
que si valéry giscard d'estaing décidé
de participer aux délibérations du
conseil constitutionnel il risquerait de
politiser la décision qui serait prise
une décision qui doit par principe se
situer au dessus de la politique est une
ombre à peser sur tous ces débats sur
les nationalisations c'est celle de
paribas dont le président pierre moussa
démissionné la semaine dernière
a été accusé d'avoir contribué à la
scission de paribas suisse mentalité des
immigrés à tenait samedi à valence
pierre mauroy et bien aujourd'hui les
banquiers européens que les
participations dans les filiales
étrangères de paribas et de toutes les
autres banques nationales is able
française se réunissaient à londres pour
définir une stratégie commune ils ne
sont pas d'accord avec le mode
d'indemnisation
bernard ap les a retrouvés mais n'a pu
les abîmer
c'est donc devant cette tour de londres
dans cet hôtel que se sont réunis les
représentants des filiales des banques
nationales is able française
il y ait eu deux réunions auxquelles ont
participé des banquiers allemands cela
c'est sûr mais très probablement aussi
des banquiers britanniques américains
belges et japonais une réunion technique
ce matin
une autre réunion plus politique semblé
t-il cet après midi mais dans les deux
cas les banques qui ont fait preuve
d'une très grande discrétion la numidie
question un moment qu'il quitte l'hôtel
par une porte dérobée par une porte de
secours
cela bien sûr pour éviter de rencontrer
quiconque à commencer par la presse il
faut noter que ce n'est sans doute pas
par hasard que londres a été choisi pour
servir de cadre à cette réunion d'abord
parce que londres cédait city la
principale place financière européenne
mais aussi parce que le gouvernement de
margaret thatcher est par nature très
hostile à tout ce qui ressemble à une
nationalisation il serait plutôt
question en grande-bretagne à l'heure
actuelle de dénationaliser
l'endroit était donc propice pour tenir
un conseil de guerre au cours duquel les
banquiers ont taquiné la stratégie
qu'ils utiliseront dans la bataille
financière qui semble décidé à livrer en
france
oui bernard ap le disait londres ait été
sans doute l'endroit rêvé pour parler
d'un tel sujet a même pas beaucoup une
nationalisation en ce moment en grande
bretagne c'est même tout le contraire on
parle surtout des nationalisations ou
même pour parler éclaire privatisation
des entreprises publiques sont toutes ou
presque en déficit ce qui n'est pas le
cas en france également profite pour se
débarrasser d'un fardeau imaginez que
vous arriviez à londres un beau matin la
tête encore pleine des titres de la
presse française
imaginez encore que vous décidez
d'acheter un journal anglais histoire de
voir de quoi l'on parle de ce côté ci de
la manche le guardian par exemple que
les et vous en première page khassawneh
bon chirurgien a assassiné sa femme et
que la société nationale des pétroles
britannique va être dénationaliser oui
vous avez bien lu dénationaliser
privatiser le gouvernement britannique
va vendre au secteur privé les intérêts
qu'il a dans cette société
le plus étonnant c'est que cette société
nationale des pétroles britannique qui
exploite comme ici les riches gisements
de la mer du nord est né il ya tout
juste cinquante du rachat par l'état
d'une société privée
l'explication à l'époque les
travaillistes étaient au pouvoir
aujourd'hui changement radical des
conservateurs sont au 10 downing street
et le premier ministre margaret thatcher
ne cache pas qu'elle met tous ses
espoirs dans le secteur privé
c'est à lui qu'il revient naturellement
de gérer l'industrie toute l'industrie
lui seul selon madame thatcher
on est capable il faut se souvenir la
différence des images qu'on a chez nous
de l'industrie d'état chez vous pour
nous c'est l'inefficacité dans le mythe
populaire est certainement dans le
milieu du parti conservateur c'est tout
à fait contraire france là vous prend
vous conseillera nous nous on pense à
brice lalonde
c'est ça la différence les travaillistes
il ya quelques années ont nationalisé
madame thatcher des nationalise si en
1984 les travaillistes reviennent au
pouvoir ont-ils renationaliser ils le
disent et je crois qu ils le feront
et il est certain que je dirais la
plupart des gens comme moi pardon mais
n'importe qui on est contre on ne veut
pas ce changement éternel entre privé et
public public privé il ya personne qui
croit que c'est ça c'est l'efficacité il
ya personne cette privatisation du
secteur public n'est sans doute pas une
surprise elle était inscrite au
programme des conservateurs
ce qui surprend en revanche c'est son
ampleur ainsi dès le mois prochain le
secteur privé devrait avoir la maîtrise
d'une partie de british aerospace
l'équivalent de macias en france et qui
était auparavant une entreprise publique
d'au moins 51% de la société nationale
des pétroles d'une partie du capital des
chemins de fer britanniques avec le
rachat des hôtels les plus prospères de
cette compagnie de la totalité de la
société nationale des transports
routiers
et jusqu'à la poste qui n'échappe pas au
changement pas question bien sûr de
dénationaliser cette vénérable
institution
mais elle n'aura plus le monopole de la
distribution du courrier un monopole
dont elle jouissait depuis plusieurs
siècles
le fonds des nationalisations ayant
laissé quelques répit car me roy donc pu
quitter paris l'esprit plus serein pour
la première étape de la tournée
d'explications qu'il veut entreprendre
en province
aujourd'hui donc la bretagne avec un
slogan maintes fois répétées de brest à
rennes dialogue et concertation
pierre-alain rien sur place qui suit
donc la tournée du premier ministre en
bretagne
pierre mauroy n'a pas failli à son image
au cours de cette première étape
bretonne de son tour de france pour
l'emploi à chaque attroupement que ce
soit à brest warren comme ici une halte
pour s'enquérir des revendications des
manifestants un hôpital pour
saint-brieuc une école de plus pour
rennes
une politique agricole garantissant les
revenus et cetera
au total au cours de ce marathon de
douze heures le premier ministre a
rencontré l'ensemble des élus d'île et
vilaine et du finistère
les représentants syndicaux et des
organisations professionnelles comme
celle du bâtiment qu de la banque
il a prononcé cinq discours et annoncé
des mesures ponctuelles comme la
création à rennes d'une maison de
l'électronique ou nationales comme
l'ouverture prochaine des mairies toute
la semaine du lundi au samedi inclus
écoutant ses interlocuteurs il s'est
intéressé aux problèmes spécifiques de
la bretagne crise du bâtiment
aménagement des ports formation
professionnelle agriculture élevage et
même le nucléaire à propos de la
suppression de plogoff
mais à tous pierre mauroy a demandé
d'aider le gouvernement dans sa lutte
contre le chômage de souscrire au fameux
contrat de solidarité
c'était le but de son voyage voilà un
voyage qui vient de s'acheter donc ce
soir par un discours bien et amis à
quelques secondes à rennes le premier
ministre qui a parlé beaucoup chômage
vous allez voir au passage que pierre
mauroy était légèrement en rit on voyage
d'aujourd'hui comme ceux que je vais
effectuer dans les semaines qui
dans votre région de france n'a pas
d'autre signification que le manifester
ma conviction que la bataille pour
l'emploi dans les mois et les années qui
viennent de peut être payée que par une
coopération exemplaire à tous les
niveaux des moyens de l'état et les
initiatives locales
mais on compte aujourd'hui haute encore
renforcé ma conviction sans la volonté
locale la volonté de l'état sera
suffisante en matière de création de
libération d'emplois le gouvernement
aidera toutes les initiatives locales je
m'en porte garant
c'est à vous sur place de les susciter
et de les imaginer
telle est la philosophie des contrats de
solidarité emploi
c'est la garantie que la solidarité
nationale viendra en matière d'emploi
apporté un concours complet aux
initiatives de solidarité locale à vous
dans votre usine dans votre entreprise
dans votre branche dans votre cas but de
dégager ou de créer des emplois à vous
de trouver les emplois adou d'assurer
les compensations financières
voilà le contrat oui tiens moi était
même très enrhumé et pourtant il faisait
beau aujourd'hui en bretagne comme très
souvent d'ailleurs lors ce goût de
l'apaisement qui contraste quelque peu
avec la montée ton ces derniers jours
dans la classe politique
on le retrouve également dans les propos
que françois mitterrand a tenu à son
retour de cancun propos tenus donc sur
antenne 2 le chef de l'état qui soit 10
par parenthèse a eu aujourd'hui 65 ans
cette employée à apaiser les tensions
entre la majorité et l'opposition à
l'assemblée
mais si la 14e journée du débat sur les
nationalisations fut aujourd'hui
relativement calme
elle était quand même très tendue
bernard pradines rang
au cours de cette journée de débats
opposition et majorité se sont à nouveau
quereller sur l'actualité du débat mais
aussi à propos des changes
mots aigres-doux remontantes à plusieurs
jours pour l'opposition il est
vraisemblable que le ton des discussions
à l'assemblée sera demain à l'occasion
d'un autre débat aussi dur que ces
derniers vont désormais les débats
seront vus parce que les débats seront
des débats de fond
il s'agit de savoir si on continue à
être en démocratie
aussi on cesse d'être en démocratie
certains propos qui ont été tenus ces
jours-ci par les responsables
socialistes plus haut niveau me laisse à
penser que nous avons quelques
inquiétudes à avoir à ce sujet pour la
majorité le problème n'est pas là la
démocratie est loin d'être en péril le
débat à l'assemblée à d'ailleurs été
tout à fait démocratique en dépit des
insultes échangées
ces noms d'oiseaux ses invectives ont
marqué tout aulong le débat sur les
nationalisations
il est évident que l'opposition a
cherché à faire de l'obstruction
systématique elle a employé pour cela
tous les moyens de la procédure
parlementaire
et après tout c'était son droit c'était
aussi notre droit de vouloir faire en
sorte que cette loi soit votée voilà ce
débat sur les nationalistes qui n'est
toujours pas terminé je le vois sur
notre écran de contrôle on vous en donne
le résultat dès que possible
françois ceyrac n'acceptera pas de
prolonger son mandat au delà du 31
décembre
c'est ce que vient d'annoncer le patron
des patrons en réponse à ceux qui lui
demandaient d'aller un petit peu plus
loin pour arbitrer la course entre les 2
yvon yvon gattaz et yvon chotard renault
toujours l'incertitude il semble bien
que l'on s'acheminait vers la fin du
conflit mais la consultation qui
viennent se tenir au département 74 de
lusine de boulogne billancourt est
quelque peu ambiguë
en gros un votant sur 2 et 1 pour un
contre un pour la reprise du travail
un contre la reprise très exactement à
106 à 112 voix l'intersyndicale se
réunit en ce moment et puisque nous
parlons voiture sachez que là le prix
des voitures va progresser de 3 à 4 et
demi pour cent sur toutes les marques
françaises dans les jours à venir
au lendemain de la manifestation
pacifiste qui a réuni plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de personnes les
organisateurs parlent même de cent mille
personnes à paris et qui a vu ensuite la
presse divisé entre partisans et
adversaires de l'urss
un sujet de concorde eu ce soir la
coopération franco soviétique en matière
spatiale
georges leclercq en effet pu pénétrer
dans la base ultra secret de baïkonour à
40 km de moscou et il a passé une
semaine avec les deux spationautes
français dont l'un sans doute de jong
chrétiens s'envolera pour l'espace sur
soyouz les dépôts show un groupe de
cosmonautes en grande banlieue de moscou
après l'entraînement la détente parmi
eux deux français
parmi eux le premier homme de l'espace
de notre pays
jean loup chrétien 43 ans qui est une
histoire vous faites quoi ici chez vous
vous êtes seul c'est énorme qui me
permet de donner à mes passe-temps
favori faut il montrer à vos risques et
périls
e
à quoi pense jean loup chrétien quand il
joue
qu'il sera le premier français aveugle
dans l'espace parmi les étoiles que
notre pays a choisi l'union soviétique
pour partenaire il est vrai que les
américains ne feront pas de tels voyages
pense-t-il à ses deux coéquipiers ma les
chefs evans tchekhov vieux routier du
cosmos
pour être comme eux jean loup chrétien
s'entraînent très durement le voici dans
la centrifugeuse de la cité des étoiles
ici ses qualités de pilote d'avion à
réaction mirage lui servent beaucoup
sa mission est essentiellement
scientifique
au menu médecine biologie métallurgie et
astronomie il aura peu de navigation
spatiale a effectué juste quelques
mesures quelques relevés les soviétiques
garde le pilotage pour eux jean loup
chrétien pense-t-il aussi à son collègue
patrick baudry 35 heures n'est pas
choisie pour ce premier vol mais il suit
exactement le même entraînement d'abord
en cas de maladie de jean loup puis au
cas où les soviétiques souhaite
poursuivre ce genre de coopération avec
nous en attendant le décollage de l'été
prochain jean loup chrétien loin de sa
famille joue sol d'un instrument qui le
rapproche déjà des étoiles deux
attentats
aujourd'hui à beyrouth et en grande
bretagne à beyrouth sur l'explosion
d'une voiture piégée a fait 15 blessés
dont deux grièvement
un mort en revanche à londres en plein
centre de la capitale
la victime était un artificier tentait
de désamorcer un paquet piégé à oxford
street
c'est à dire vraiment plein centre de
londres en sous sol d'un snack-bar un
endroit très commerçant et très
fréquenté également plusieurs blessés
l'ira qui a aussitôt revendiqué cet
attentat
elle avait pas venu une heure avant
un message du colonel kadhafi à françois
mitterrand mais ni tripoli ni paris
n'ont dévoilé la teneur de ce message
un naufrage dramatique au large de miami
un bateau en bois qui transportait
quelque 67 réfugiés haïtiens a sombré à
moins d'un kilomètre des côtes
une trentaine de personnes ont péri
noyées voilà plus de six mois que des
centaines de haïtiens quittent leur pays
et se dirige lascivement essentiellement
vers les états unis
à tel point que ronald reagan a dû
décider il y à un mois des mesures
radicales pour mettre fin à cette
immigration chômage
paul nahon et jean rey reviennent de
floride
ces têtes il y a quelques semaines sur
les côtes de floride une centaine
d'haïtiens étaient venus s'échouer
volontairement sur les côtes américaines
après un voyage qui avait duré plus d'un
mois dans les mers des caraïbes
comme d'autres il fui haïti l'un des
pays les plus pauvres du monde et l'une
des dictatures de droite les plus durs
de la région depuis trois ans cinquante
mille haïtiens ont tenté ce voyage et
beaucoup sont morts de faim et de soif
avant d'avoir toucher l'héritage de
l'amérique mais les services de
l'immigration seront extrêmement sévère
sur les conditions d'accueil et la
plupart des réfugiés sont renvoyés parce
qu'aussitôt et par avion vers haïti le
gouvernement américain semble en effet
faire une distinction entre les bons et
les mauvais réfugiés les bons sont ceux
qui fuient par exemple cuba les mauvais
sont ceux là qui quittent les pays amis
des etats-unis
le format réfugiés pour l'éthique
économique plus tôt
et vous croyez qu'ils vont vous garder
ici oui ils les américains pouvaient
nous aider
c'est pour cette raison que nous sommes
et pourquoi vous avez choisi l'amérique
et bien parce que c'est la grille l'âge
ne semble pas peur aujourd'hui les
garde-côtes américains ont pris des
mesures encore plus draconiennes
ils ont établi une ceinture de sécurité
pour refouler
tous ces nouveaux boat people pour le
centième anniversaire de la naissance de
picasso il y avait quelques 4000
personnes pour faire la queue et pour
voir le fameux guernica qui est exposé
désormais au musée du prado à madrid
pour la première fois les espagnols
avaient le droit de le voir vous savez
que picasso ne souhaitait pas que son
oeuvre soit exposé en espagne avant le
rétablissement des libertés bien c'est
aujourd'hui chose faite et patricia cost
et patrick de rien ont assisté au vécu
cet événement hier matin pour les
espagnols il fallait être là et très
nombreux c'était presque une
manifestation autant pour garnica que
par la démocratie et on a applaudi à
l'ouverture des portes du musée
je suis heureux après 45 ans et enfin le
retour de la démocratie
je suis heureux mais un peu frustré la
toile me déçoit du corps c'est le jour
de la réconciliation la démocratie il
faut la protéger
elle a six ans c'est un âge fragile
derrière une vitre anti balles l'oeuvre
et tout au fond à six mètres du public
ont créé à deux extrémismes l'extrême
droite
ils ont déjà vitriolé une exposition de
dessins de picasso il ya quelques années
et puis il y a le basque garnica est une
ville basque exterminés pendant la
guerre civile
nous avons les morts et vous le tableau
distille
rien à voir
vient nous expliquer le tableau à 200
kilomètres de madrid
dans un tout petit village le maire a
demandé aux enfants de copier les
tableaux de picasso sur les murs est la
nuit ils projetaient des diapositives
pour en faire le décalque le jour on
mettait les couleurs la couleur dans les
pieds rails de cette chaire à ou avant
il n'y avait que le bleu du ciel devant
la maison du curé guernica quand les
villageois se la raconte l'histoire de
toutes les guerres préhistorique d'appui
tellado vous le trouvez triste le
tableau oui triste
pourquoi parce qu'il ya eu la guerre ici
ça a été une lutte à couteaux tirés avec
des arcs et comme on dit des baïonnettes
des arbalète avec des flèches
on est rentré dans des grottes avec des
couteaux et on a trouvé des centaines de
morts
comme ci comme ça comme si comme dans
l'temps blanc doc et nous ce que vous
pensez que cela peut recommencer
nous ne veut pas il faut négocier un
accord et cela dépend de nos chefs de
nos ministres l'espagne a aujourd'hui
l'une des constitutions les plus
modernes d'europe
le citoyen à système de défense est de
droit très sophistiqué garnica au pays
basque exterminer un dimanche jour de
marché c'était il ya 45 ans un hold up à
paris il y a un petit peu plus d'une
heure trois employés du crédit du nord
dans le 16e arrondissement rue théophile
gautier ont été légèrement blessée par
des malfaiteurs qui ont forcé six à sept
petits coffres réservé aux clients avant
de prendre la fuite
l enquête sur l'assassinât du juge
michel selon son père le magistrat était
sur le point de prononcer plusieurs
inculpations dans une grosse affaire
on n'a pas tué mon fils par vengeance at
il dit dans françois on a commis un
crime très inventif et puis aux assises
de roi
la première journée du procès claude
épices qui se dit victime depuis 12 ans
d'une erreur judiciaire et dont le face
à face aujourd'hui avec le président de
la cour d'assises a été étonnant pour ne
pas dire poignant cloutier rire à
compans il donc ces neuf jurés devront
lorsqu'ils entendent un magistrat
président de la cour d'assises dialoguer
avec courage et honnêteté
avec l'accusé lui dire ma position
inconfortable votre et tragique
il faut aborder ce procès dans un esprit
d'apaisement et non pas d'acharnement à
quoi pense-t-il ses neuf jurés en
écoutant ainsi un juge reconnaître
implicitement que la révolte de knome
épices et celle du désespoir d'un homme
et qu'elle s'explique
quel sentiment de malaise pour ses jurés
que d'avoir à juger a condamné peut être
un homme pour des faits avérés de vol
alors que cet homme parfois maladroit
parfois émouvant dit son innocence et ce
qu'il a vécu
la prison c'est insupportable quand on
est coupable
cette inimaginable quand on est innocent
a crié roger knobelspiess un moment tout
à l'heure
roger knobelspiess reconnaît les vols
commis pendant sa permission de sortie
mais songez mesdames et messieurs les
jurés remarquer maître henri leclerc son
défenseur que roger knobelspiess à 34
ans et que depuis l'âge de 16 ans il n'a
pas connu la liberté plus de deux ans
sport mais aussi santé un concurrent de
paris versailles une épreuve
d'athlétisme sur route un demi marathon
à peu près est mort hier soir en
franchissant la ligne d'arrivée il a
succombé à une crise cardiaque
et pourtant voilà deux mois qu'il
s'entraînait pour cette course alors
bien sûr il n'est pas question de
condamner la mode du jogging qui fait
largement plus de bien que de mal mais
il est bon de rappeler quelques données
essentielles de prudence
jean ma mère
il était si fière plus de 50000 à new
york 25000 à paris des rhein il ya eu
aussi cette année le marathon de paris
les 24 heures de vie tels les randonnées
pédestres les occidentaux n'arrêtent pas
de courir accusé longtemps d'être obèse
sédentaires ils ont compris la leçon
la mode et la société de consommation et
dans ils se sont mis à se dépenser à
tout prix à caen perdions la sondages
récents montrent que deux français sur
trois sont intéressés à se maintenir en
forme
les cas sur quatre fait du sport assez
régulièrement à titre indicatif le
chiffre devant des chaussures de sport a
triplé en cinq ans passant de 6 millions
de paires à près de 20 millions
aujourd'hui
cette mobilisation générale expliquerait
en partie la diminution des maladies
cardiovasculaires il ne faudrait pas que
l'accident plonge dans l'immobilité des
millions de personnes décidées à vous
jouez bien qu'exceptionnels cette mort
n'est pas la première qui s'est produit
dans une course populaire bénéfique
le sport a aussi cédé
non
à partir de 35 ans toute personne qui
veut se mettre à faire un sport comme
par exemple 12 km ou 20 km en footing ou
des sports d'accélération plus brutales
comme le tennis ou le squash devra
vérifier qu'elle n'a pas de facteur de
risque cardiovasculaire c'est à dire
c'est à dire les trois principaux sont
tabac élévation du cholestérol et
élévation de la tension artérielle est
ce que ce n'est pas pour ça qu'il
cherche à faire du sport ça peut aider à
corriger c'est à dire que parmi les
sportifs ya moins de fumeurs que chez
ceux qui ne font pas de sport mais il
faut départ corriger ces facteurs pour
se situer dans une zone sans danger car
ces courses épisodiques ont fait une
fois ou deux par an c'est mauvais mais
c'est pas mauvais disons que c'est une
bonne chose dans la mesure où ça fait
prendre conscience aux gens de la
nécessité de veut avoir une activité
sportive de prendre conscience de son
corps et de s'occuper de sa bonne santé
mais il faut avoir un minimum
d'entraînement ne pas se lancer dans 20
km à faire sans âme sans avoir couru le
mois où les deux mois précédents alors
quand on a pas d'entraînement caisse
pour vous recommander alors les sports
accélération progressive la marche le
vélo la natation
le nouveau journal auto défense il faut
comprendre défense de l'automobiliste un
mouvement qui est pour la suppression de
l'obligation de la ceinture de sécurité
et des codes envie et puis la météo
maintenant avec alain gillot-pétré et je
vous annonce pour demain le passage
d'une nouvelle zone où depuis et oui que
voulez vous c'est comme celà l'océan
atlantique et bourré perturbations qui
vont nous intéresser pendant une bonne
partie de la semaine les extrêmes des
températures élevées à 13 heures
aujourd'hui par le média national il
faisait 4 degrés c'est le minimum à
dijon maximum 14 degrés à nice pas à
marseille
enfin pour information sachez qu'il est
tombé 54 mm de pluie à toussus-le-noble
en région parisienne s'est tenue cette
considérable la prévision pour demain
passage d'une zone pluvieuse et très
nuageuse donc demain qui se situera en
milieu de journée de l'aquitaine au
massif central et au nord-est
donc là il faut savoir pas mal de pluie
mais tout de même moins moins que cette
nuit à la vente cette zone des nuages le
matin sur le sud est donc mais
progressivement des éclaircies qui de
nouveau disparaîtront pour laisser la
place aux nuages à cause de cette zone
de pluie est derrière cette
depuis bien là le temps sera variable
avec des éclaircies des passages nuageux
résidait la compagnie encore d'averses
la prévision de température pour demain
bien sensiblement les mêmes températures
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas chaud le matin
et c'est pas faux non plus l'après midi
l'après midi de 9 à 17 degrés simplement
en dessous des normales enfin notre
éphémérides pour demain mardi 27 octobre
7h31 17h38 teaser de lever du coucher de
soleil à paris c'est la nouvelle lune
demain il a fait des émules in bien joli
prénom et pour ce faire vous avez deux
rendez-vous avec l'actualité
à 23h10 hervé claude pour le tout
dernier journal de l'information mais
auparavant à 20h30 où tu t'es pas ce
journal dont après une page de publicité
un magazine que vous prévient jacques
séguy et toute la rédaction d'antenne 2
sur l'argent des français alors nous
avons centaine autre enquête sur une
petite ville
annonay dans l'ardèche et trois de nos
reporters bruno albin ont régalé
françoise kramer essaierons de vous
montrer un petit peu ce que possèdent
les français quel rapport
ils ont avec l'argent bonsoir à tous à
demain matin